[Música]
salud en directo américa de france a 24
y ya me acompaña en el estudio marina
sardiña donde hoy vamos a retomar un
estudio de la revista nation que
analizamos el día de ayer que dice que
el 58 por ciento de las infecciones
humanas conocidas se verán agravadas por
el cambio climático de
375 enfermedades analizamos analizadas
por los investigadores
218 ya se agravaron por este
calentamiento global marina muy buen día
buenos días y como decíamos ayer esto
señala la estrecha relación entre cambio
climático y salud y para ello tenemos
con nosotros a camilo mora quien
investigó y él lideró esta investigación
él es él el es profesor e investigador
colombiano y está con nosotros para
hablar de esto muchas gracias por
acompañarnos camilo lo primero que
quería preguntar es qué es lo más
novedoso de estos hallazgos y de este
estudio
o sea por mucho tiempo nosotros hemos
sabido que el cambio climático baten las
consecuencia de la enfermedad es de
hecho un par de reportajes que hicieron
hace un momento hablaban de las
inundaciones y los incendios forestales
nosotros sabemos que como consecuencia
de eso hay muchos vectores que se les
estamos alterando el hábitat y en esa
motivación de sus vectores buscar un
hábitat nuevo vienen en contacto con los
seres humanos y ahí se transmiten esas
enfermedades solo hemos salido por mucho
tiempo pero en realidad no sabemos
cuántas en este artículo lo que nosotros
decidimos hacer recuerda todas las
enfermedades que han afectados los seres
humanos desde el final del imperio
romano hasta el coi night in analizamos
todas y sistemáticamente buscamos como
cada una de esas enfermedades ha sido
afectada por cambios climáticos y lo que
encontramos es que más del 58 por ciento
de esas enfermedades en algún momento
han sido afectadas por el cambio
climático
camilo muy buen día los saludo un gusto
tenerlo aquí con nosotros en nuestro
programa sobre todo nuestra sección de
salud por supuesto le pregunté entonces
de este estudio las enfermedades que
destacan que pueden agravarse más
rápidamente debido a este calentamiento
global
si osea vieron mucha de hecho
encontramos como tú mencionas en su
momento 218 de 300 y pico enfermedades
que han afectado los seres humanos y hay
unas que son muy comunes de entender por
ejemplo tú miras esa inundación que
estaba ocurriendo en surcorea como
estaba mencionando tu cuando esa agua
empiece a bajar va a dejar una cantidad
de estanques y eso son partes donde van
a ver una crecimiento de mosquitos la
cosa más violenta y todos los virus y
bacterias que transmiten a través de los
mosquitos obviamente van a prosperar y
cualquier persona que esté allí iba a
ser infectada también encontramos por
ejemplo los incendios y las olas en las
sequías las sequías fue interesante
porque resulta que en la mitad del monte
por allá de maynas de todo los animales
que haya peleando con sus propios
patógenos animales también allá pero
cuando nosotros llegamos allá con la
sequía a través del cambio climático
estos animales son forzados a buscar
nuevos hábitats y en esa búsqueda de
hábitat desafortunadamente llegan en
contacto con seres humanos
y ahí es donde se
desatan estas enfermedades que vemos hoy
en día camilo y estás hablando del
cambio climático como uno de los
factores principales pero que otros
factores climáticos extremos derivados
de éste climático pueden hacer
proliferar nuevos patógenos o empeorar
estos de asistentes
eso es una pregunta muy muy buena de
hecho porque nosotros siempre pensamos
en el cambio climático como que el
planeta está calentando y lo cual es
verdad pero resulta que con ese
calentamiento las tasas de evaporación
del agua también están incrementando
como consecuencia de eso en algunas
partes tiene sequías y tú si tu combinas
calor con sequías tienen las condiciones
perfectas para la ola de calor e
incendios como demostramos allí en otros
lugares la misma evaporación del agua lo
que hace es que mucha agua suba y
llenemos a ningún lugar el agua puede
ser restablecida y como resultado tienen
mucha evaporación lo que resulta en unas
precipitaciones muy grandes que se
terminan convirtiendo también en
inundaciones entonces como tú te das
cuenta esa cosa sola que estamos
haciendo de meterle más de gases de
granja los gases a la atmósfera está en
realidad activando el calentamiento pero
ese calentamiento tiene otras
ramificaciones y así como los seres
humanos están siendo afectados resulta
que todos esos patógenos que están en el
ambiente también están siendo afectados
y en algunos casos están mejorando
para afectarnos a nosotros camino le
preguntó por las poblaciones más
propensas a sufrir de estas secuelas
climáticas de las enfermedades
obviamente que se que se propagan y se
agravan debido a esta crisis climática
pues mira que esa pregunta es muy
interesante porque 1 dvd así de entrada
uno pensaría que son los países más
pobres los que van a sufrir más pero
cuando tú te miras lo que pasó con el
cob y tú te diste cuenta que en realidad
incluso los países más desarrollados del
mundo cuando nos enfrentamos una
epidemia como 'el hobbit' se colapsaron
yo os lo digo en eeuu y eso fue
increíble en los niveles de bloqueo que
se llenó se generó haya o sea que esa
pregunta que tú haces y obviamente los
países en desarrollo les va a ir mal
pues porque no tenemos la
infraestructura para desarrollar para
enfrentarnos a esos - puedes pensar que
vamos a ser capaces de desarrollar esas
vacunas pero el kobe cambio dio a
indicar de que incluso los países ricos
están propensos a estas enfermedades
claro pues camilo lamentablemente se nos
acaba el tiempo para hablar de este
estudio tan interesante que por supuesto
podemos estar aquí hablando marina 5
horas sobre el tema o mucho camilo la
verdad pues nada agradecerte por
acompañarnos esta mañana de miércoles
aquí en directo américa de fernán sentí
4 un gran abrazo y por supuesto las
puertas de esta casa están abiertas a
cuando quiera hablar de cualquier otro
tipo de investigación y esto un abrazo y
muchas gracias por invitarme camilo mora
investigadora y también que lideró esta
investigación de la que estábamos
hablando hace un momento marina como
siempre también muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta mesa de trabajo
despedimos salud para pasar a hablar con
las mentes de deportes